for the past 45 years no writer has
taken a bigger blowtorch to the sacred
cows of American life than libertarian
humorous PJ O'Rourke as a writer at
National Lampoon in the early 1970s he
co-authored best-selling parodies of
high school yearbooks and Sunday
newspapers we're going up the left side
of Iraq throwing a left hook towards
Baghdad for Rolling Stone the Atlantic
and other publications a rock traveled
to war zones and other disaster areas
chronicling the folly of military and
economic intervention chaos in 1991 he
came out with parliament of wars which
explained why politicians should really
be the last people to have any power
subtitled a lone humorist attempts to
explain the entire US government this
international bestseller probably mented
more libertarians than any book since
free to choose or Atlas Shrugged more
recently or work published a critical
history of his own baby boom generation
and an account of Donald Trump's
surprising 2016 campaign victory his new
book none of my business
explains why he's not rich and neither
are you
it's partly the result of hanging out
with wealthy money managers and
businessmen and what they've taught him
over the years about creating meaning
and value in an ever richer and crazier
world it covers everything from social
media to learning how to drink in war
zone so why the Chinese may be more
American than US citizens i sat down
with O'Rourke to talk about all that the
good and bad of Donald Trump and why
being an old white man just isn't what
it used to be Joe thanks for talking to
Reason oh you're very welcome
but why should we be talking to you I
mean you go you you spend a couple of
pages clearing your threat at the
beginning of the book saying that you
you are the last person in the world
that anybody should be talking to about
getting rich or about business yeah but
about economics I hope I'm not the very
last person that people should be
talking to about economics I suppose the
reason to talk to me from reasons point
of view would be that I am aware and I'm
afraid a lot of people aren't that
market freedoms are at the ABS
core of freedom that you cannot have
freedom you cannot have anything that
resembles libertarian principles of
individual liberty individual dignity
individual responsibility they can't
exist without market freedoms and first
and foremost in market freedom is
private property and first and foremost
and private property is our individual
property in ourselves we have to own
ourselves and we have to own the product
of our Liberty our dignity and our
responsibility you know
socialism is making a comeback at least
that's a brand name yeah so are you
worried about that or do you think that
that's just kind of you know a new way
of packaging old kind of statist ideas
or is there a fundamental shift going
back to a kind of pre Cold War
understanding of what what capitalism is
and what socialism it concerns me a
little bit it concerns me first and
foremost because it's it's a recurrence
of resurgence in an age-old fallacy
which is the zero-sum fallacy is that
you know it doesn't matter how rich
other people are it's not a zero-sum
game more money can be made more Goods
can be produced there may be a very few
goods that are that are zero-sum
beachfront property but as we speak
Florence is bearing down on the
beachfront and who wants any property
and we could always make more and we can
always drink we're about to make more
beachfront property in that because you
have too many slices of the pizza does
not mean that I have to eat the box we
can bake more pizza and and that's the
the ultimate fallacy that all the
collectivist and socialist statist ideas
about the economy rest upon is that
there's no there's a fixed amount of
good things out there in the world and
they are
unfairly distributed are the good things
in the world being unfairly distributed
yes but how do you answer that you
answer that by making more good things
in the world and in an era of I won't
say untrammeled free markets but
relatively we've had an era of relative
relative peace relative free trade
relative market free market dominance in
the world and in that period say since
the late 20th century to now the number
of abject leap impoverished people
number of people living on less than a
dollar a day has been cut in half and
that damn it is progress at one point
you write that socialism communism
fascism and crony capitalism are all
forms of capitalism what what do you
mean by that well capitalism is just a
description of how businesses are built
and products are made and services are
provided it always requires a certain
amount of material input usually money
also time and effort and that
accumulation or that the the the the
means by which production is is is
created that accumulation of means the
time the skills the effort and indeed
the cash it's necessary to make anything
that is capital and nothing is produced
without some form of capitalism so
capitalism of the small sea really
doesn't have anything to do with the
arguments about the outcomes of capital
one of the things that's really
interesting especially early in the book
you you kind of recount some of your
adventures in war zones more in super
deprived societies where there's still a
lot of trade and commerce going on how
does that feed into this idea that you
know something like capitalism it's
always going on and then it's a question
of do you clear the way so that it can
be done more efficiently or more
humanely
well yeah you certainly try to I mean
one of the great lessons I learned is
20 years as a war correspondent was that
the under no circumstance does the
profit motive go away everybody you may
think oh my gosh I'm in the middle of
the as I was when I first started this
in the 1980s I'm in the middle of the
civil war in Lebanon and this is
absolutely economically destructive and
yet an economy was operating there got
me having a lot to do with drug and gun
smuggling and and other unsavory
activities but nonetheless there was an
economy then also you have to remember
that not everybody counts profit the
same way we all hope to profit with
money because money is necessary to life
but other people want to profit with
power too or they want to profit with
fear perhaps of their reputation as
terrifying warriors they may want to
profit with not to make a pawn but they
may want to profit with extolling the
works of the Prophet they may want to
profit by converting people by free will
or otherwise and even the good people
involved in these conflicts the the aid
workers and the P and the peacemakers
they're piling up treasure in heaven
presumably so you know they're there
they're counting their profit and virtue
when you go when you think back to you
know and you're talking about Lebanon in
the 80s I mean you are so you hit all
the hot spots and I did one Albania you
know pre the pre liberation Albania
former Yugoslavia pre apartheid South
Africa when when you look back at the at
the you know the absolute you know
foreign hell holes or [ __ ] holes that
you you've reported from in in the 80s
or through the early 90s let's you know
let's call it before the the glorious
21st century arrived do you feel like
we're [ __ ]
you know that we're much better off now
as a world despite all of the problems
or are we always kind of teetering on
the edge of sliding back into abject
kind of chaos yes big wide that we are
in
we are in a measurably better place than
we were toward the end of the 20th
century you can see it in life
expectancies you can see it in all sorts
of World Health Organization statistics
we are always on the verge of chaos one
of the things that makes me not not only
a libertarian but also a conservative is
in an attempt to conserve what
civilization there is out there we're
always in danger of sliding back into
chaos but several decades of several
decades of relative free trade of
relatively good attention to market
principles in places like China and even
in the ex-soviet Union certainly in in
Eastern Europe and in most of the
developing world have brought measurable
progress and although we read a lot and
hear a lot about war we're not actually
in one the the mortality from war in the
21st century has been much smaller than
at any point during the 20th century the
20th century was the most war plagued
century in the history of mankind was a
horrible century when great material
progress was made in certain places but
horrible horrible conflicts were fought
terrible ideologies were put forward
millions upon millions upon millions of
people were murdered for the sake of
those ideologies yeah we're in a better
place or acknowledge that stay there
what in terms of trade and kind of free
free markets around the world global
free trade you know obviously Donald
Trump you wrote a book about the
emergence of Donald Trump and how we
managed to win yes
talking to a lot of people that were
supporting him on the campaign trail do
you think he is is a serious threat to
global free trade or is he you know just
kind of posturing who who is the general
you talked about who's great on the
horse bulan sure yes yeah there might be
his original mane on horse is he just a
kind of you know man on a horse like
primping around I think
touchwood and that that he's mostly
a clown figure on this there is no doubt
that we are involved in a certain number
of trade agreements around the world
where our trading partners are not
perhaps living up to the letter or let
alone the spirit of those trade
agreements the nature of trade
agreements is such that people are
always saying oh they'll be perfect free
trade except for our regulations about
bruised fruit you know except for our in
case of the United States
it was auto safety regulations that
forced all foreign automakers to make an
entirely different car to export to the
United we are very sensitive people here
yes we have and I guess we're really bad
drivers currently so yeah and anyway I
would say that yes our some of our trade
agreements probably need a bit of
renegotiation this is not the way I'd go
about it the way that Trump is going
about it but if he scares people into
obeying the letter of the trade
regulations or no I think I don't think
he knows much about what he's talking
about I don't think he has any idea what
he's talking about here but in pursuit
of free trade we want reciprocal trade
agreements and if his clowning around
leads to that on the other hand it could
lead to a trade war or a smoot-hawley
Tariff returned to protectionism of the
1930s and that would be utterly
disastrous we'll see at one point you
write capitalism has transmogrified and
you have a whole section about mutant
capitalism what do you mean by that well
an odd sort of thing has happened
particularly with the tech giants is
that the the typical model of investing
I would say the Warren Buffett model of
investing where you do due diligence on
companies that have been been in
business for a long time that have a
certain kind of cash flow and a model of
operation and you try to find the most
valuable those companies selling at the
most reasonable price it's kind of gone
out the window lately at least in the
news I don't think it's really gone out
the window but the news reports are all
about these companies that some of them
have never made a profit very few of
them distribute their profit and
dividends the the bet is all on our
enormous growth they've had enormous
growth already they've come out of
nowhere it's sometimes in the case of
something like Facebook it's kind of
hard to figure out what the product
actually is or if there is a product and
this has muddied the waters for ordinary
investors and and you know it worries me
but anytime you have a major change in
technology and the advent of the AI
world the digital transformation is
certainly is one of these economic
transformations there's a whole lot of
scamming going on on the margins of
these big changes you know it would have
been great to invest in the corporate
giants that the when when the Industrial
Revolution was coming along but wouldíve
you would you have invested in the right
one would you've invested in the
railroad that actually made it across
the United States or would you have
invested in the railroad that had an odd
gauge and went to Decatur I I'm I'm
guessing based on my track history I
would have been deep in canals yes yes I
would is this is railroads came in and
just as just as the interstate highway
system I would have been investing in
railroads
well you know the kind of origin of a
lot of this material is that you were
writing for a group called Stansbury
research and they had put out of
magazine called American consequences
haloo okay and so how does how does your
sense of investment advice and obviously
nothing in this interview or perhaps
everything in the senator should be
taken as investment yes very energy a
lot immediately but how
how does powering around with people who
are professional money managers and
investors change the way that you think
about stuff does it give you a sense
that you know what I can figure this out
or are like I have no [ __ ] you know it
gives me it gives me it gives me no
sense that I can figure this out
fortunately I married a woman who was
she was a business major it's all in her
hands I have absolutely no idea if we
have a portfolio and if we do what it's
invested in could be a thousand shares
of Berkshire Hathaway could be a
thousand but Klein's something built
bill or what's-his-name Mad Money guy
you know Cramer Jim Cramer yeah I've
pulled out of his behind on here sure I
don't know but what it is for me is a
whole new wonderful subject matter just
at a moment when my traditional subject
matter which has been politics has been
become poisonous and and poisonously
boring and I just don't want anything to
do with it at the moment and now I've
discovered a new bloodsport and it is so
much fun
watching people frantically trying to
make money and frantically trying to
keep from losing money and I I love that
kind of day-to-day capitalism the way I
love the NFL not only is it a great game
a fantastic spectacle but I get to see
all the guys who shoved me into my
locker in high school break each other's
legs what's what's the what's the
possible downside now hanging around
these guys who actually know what
they're talking about first place
they're endlessly feeding me good
material not good material for
investment we couldn't material to think
about and to write about and and they're
fun people
they're fun focused knowledgeable people
and they don't care much about politics
and what a wonderful era to be in to
find some people that don't what has
made politics so poisonous I think
everybody to hear that statement is to
agree with it but what's what's the
poison well cult of personality for one
thing we must always remain a nation of
laws not of men or persons I guess we
say these days is that starting funnily
enough Ronald Reagan made
a little bit to blame not because he
wasn't a good person I can I consider
him to be a very good person but he did
bring a little touch of show business to
national politics and then you got the
Clinton administration and the Clinton
administration was just one analyst like
reality TV horrible dr. Phil no it was
it was the the this this public
trainwreck mess mass media mass and
we've never really recovered from that
we got a little gravitas back in a way
with with George W and then with Obama
whatever disagreements I may have with
Obama I can't say it was an undignified
president and but was there you know you
mentioned a cult personality it was
there something to Obama where you I
mean you weren't supposed to disagree
with him or to disagree well he had a
personality thing going to I think it
was you know not so much his own fault
the fault of certain of his supporters
that well once they put out what was
essentially the Che Guevara poster you
know the Obama our Savior I've got to
say that in his favor that he never
acted like he was that person he
actually the man has rather minimal
charisma thank goodness yeah I think
that's a good thing I think politicians
should have no charisma whatsoever so
you're waiting for Walter Mondale I'm
waiting for Walter Mondale yes I
certainly am and and and any thinking
Democrat should be waiting for we should
all be waiting for Ike and and Walter
Mondale become what how is Trump how
much is he grading on you and it's not
just Trump but then he calls forth I
guess this is part of the poison Trump
is certainly poisonous to discourse
because he makes everything about
himself you know at the most base level
but then he conjures forth or maybe he's
the reaction to equally poisonous
things coming from the other side he
does he calls monsters forth from the
briny depths there's no doubt of it on
the left and on the right both the you
know the shock horror of the liberal
left at Trump totally plays into his
hands and it totally plays into the
hands of the the sort of angry alt-right
it's really brought all the most
unpleasant factors in in American
society right to the floor and but the
thing that grates me is that I've got
three kids and they're now aged 14 to 21
I'm done with raising toddlers I've been
through that I don't want to do it again
and to have a toddler in the White House
the next type for you change it's gonna
be your own well put sad thought but
well put so how do your kids respond to
a marine because they're growing in a
world of kind of I capitalism of this
post-industrial you know where Amazon
Facebook Twitter Google YouTube all of
the tech giants that you write about in
a very kind of forthright way as
transmogrification a mutant form of
capitalism from where you are how do you
communicate to your kids what is
different and do they care they do care
I don't think my kids are particularly
impressed by the AI world they use it of
course they're adept with it or much
more depth than I am but it and of
course they're in constant communication
I mean my parents great complaint would
be you know he never writes he never
calls he never comes home we don't know
what he's doing you know we haven't
heard from him in six months now it is
we haven't heard from her in six minutes
you know my eldest daughter is in doing
a semester abroad in Budapest at the
moment and but would you know that no
she might as well be in the next room I
mean she and her mother are skyping
every 10 minutes and you know she writes
typical of kids today no I'm in this
restaurant in pest
what should I order it sits as a little
exhausting as far as I'm concerned but
they are skeptical of this world at the
same time my my eldest daughter is
probably most articulate about it and I
kind of interviewed her when she was in
high school about and she finds it a
little exhausting this continuing
connectedness she says that you know in
girl society at least it stirs up all
sorts of emotions that probably should
be allowed to rest overnight you know
and and she said she wishes she used her
social media less and I don't think she
uses it enormous ly she doesn't spend
all of her time on snapchat or whatever
it is
snapchat is the one tech giant that you
seem to really not believe it in the
book I in many ways I don't believe in
in any of them you know I look at
something like Facebook and then I ask
the kids and they go so for old people
but it's it's like the community
bulletin board my and my eldest daughter
again good analyst of this thing so we
still use it my friends and I still use
it because it's a way to get out a broad
message to if we're going to have a big
open house at the sorority house you
know this is our way of getting this out
to everyone she said it is functionally
it's the bulletin board at the community
center yeah what do you think about
there are in in the political arena both
on the right and the left I mean just a
couple weeks ago we had social media
hearings about social media now you know
major players from Facebook and Twitter
we're called to the carpet say you know
what you're not doing enough to do our
bidding are you worried about you know
Google Facebook Twitter Amazon having
monopolies in a way that conjure up the
old you know a US Steel or well they're
two countries and royal two questions in
here basically the thing is it should
come as no surprise I can't say it
worries me because it's so unsurprising
that it doesn't
really rise to the level of worry but it
is a shame nothing grows up nothing is
created that politics doesn't want to
get a hand on either to time well to
both tax and to regulate if it moves
regulated if it profits tax it and so
all this new economy is kind of falls
outside the the traditional parameters
of regulation and indeed in some cases
of Taxation and so naturally the
politicians are rushing in there to
regulate and say they hate for there to
be any power base other than politics
and this happens to include plenty of
Republicans is there not just a
democratic this is a bipartisan problem
then we come to to the monopoly question
and what's interesting about the tech
giants is that they have in effect
created a new kind of monopoly I mean
they're not monopolistic in the sense
that they've bought up everything
they're not monopolistic in the sense
that the barriers to entry of their
businesses are so high that no one could
overcome them but more out of there a
kind of monopoly of convenience it is a
pain in the neck to use ten search
engines it is a pain in the neck to use
ten forms of social media so people tend
to gravitate to one search engine they
tend to gravitate to to two to one form
of social media the search engine in
particular is that and the more people
who gravitate to that search engine and
use that search engine the more other
people are lured into using that but
then you mentioned something like Amazon
has something like it at the time you
were writing five percent of retail it's
risen is six yes yes so that the idea
that commanding every aspect Amazon is
some sort of retail monopoly is patently
ridiculous yes let you say it's five or
six percent of the retail trade in in
the United States and a lot of it is
flow through
there are freestanding REITs not owned
by all owned by Amazon by any means I
mean most of Amazon's business is to
flow through a business it comes from
existing retailers through Amazon out to
out to the customers and there's nothing
that prevents someone else or a million
other people from creating their own
Amazon type delivery systems and many
fairly powerful retailers have done so
and are doing so I think where the
question of monopoly arises Google would
be a better place to look because so
many customers are using that search
engine that search engine has an
extraordinary power the answer to this
is not government regulation the answer
to this is a better search engine and
I'm sure plenty of people are working on
it and I don't think any of these tech
phenomenon will be long lasting
and a sense of its this is not my bell
this is not the Union Pacific Railroad
this is not US Steel in its old 19th
century form these are not industrial
entities this isn't even Ford GM and
Chrysler these are not century long
industrial entities and at one point you
you have a chart in the book which I
think a lot of people are familiar with
where you look at you know what
companies were in the the top of you
know whether it's the fortune 500 or the
S&P yes in 1950 or 1960 versus now do
you feel like that churn is continuing
or also they've been speeding up yeah it
might even be speeding up on it and I
guess to go back to the question of like
the generational gap between people who
were born in an ear of I don't know what
to call them exactly the kind of like
meatspace widget provider companies yes
versus stuff now that is you know it's
everywhere around us and it and
it defines us but it's less physical
what is is there an essential connection
that you want to or memory or piece of
knowledge from that pass that you want
to make sure that younger people
understand well it would simply be that
although the products of my day were
physical and and and and the products of
of today seem to be more conceptual the
same free-market principles apply to the
manufacture of Ford's as they do to the
manufacture of social media platforms
okay and then so - and I'm going because
it comes in for a fair both snapchat and
the Pontiac Pontiac Aztek but for a fair
amount of abuse in your book so snapchat
is essentially the post-industrial
version of the Pontiac Aztek well I
think well I'll say that I have no idea
what I'm talking about it's I'm not even
sure what snapchat is I think you know
it's something it's something the way
the kids can talk to each other that
allegedly disappears although as my
daughter the tech savvy daughter points
out dad it doesn't really disappear
because somebody can take a screenshot
of what you've said on snapchat so it's
not really a private she's perfectly
aware that she would need an encrypted
channel to have actually private and at
this point you have no idea what's going
on but you're very I don't about what
there does I will you know she gets on
some some sensitive subject I will say
honey let's go to a landline do you
worry at all about the kind of privacy
implications and and and why do you
worry about them because it's from a
kind of traditional political you know
right-of-center libertarian conservative
saying of course you don't want the
government knowing anything and you
don't want your social security number
to become like a personal ID card or
something no
which it obviously did but now not only
does the government but every
corporation I mean Google Facebook
Amazon thank you so much but why well I
think well why is simple enough
about a year ago my tuxedo suspenders
wore out after three decades you mean
like that is the worst humblebrag I've
ever heard thank you you have not gained
weight in 30 years congratulations so I
go on Brooks Brothers online and order a
new pair of tuxedo suspenders very
pricey I may say but it's an expense
that only comes along every 25 or 30
years so and I'm probably on my last set
of tuxedo suspenders for months
afterward I was plagued by ads from
suspender makers you know it had gotten
in there that I bought a pair of
suspenders and all of a sudden I am like
suspender central I don't want anymore
suspenders I needed I needed 135 years
ago or whatever it was and I need one
now and that's it and and Brooks
Brothers themselves knowing full well I
just bought a pair of suspenders they're
trying to sell me more suspenders I
didn't I thought God imagine if I had
ordered an anatomically correct oh yes
it's all out there and I think that it's
it's a problem we'll get over anytime
there's a new method of communication
there is a new method of violating the
privacy of that when when when when
regular postal free postal delivery was
invented so were people reading your
letters you know when the telegraph line
was invented so were people tapping at
the telephone line I mean this is a
there's nothing new about this really I
can ruin my grandmother say saying never
write anything in a letter that you
wouldn't shout from the rooftops and in
my saying to her grandma I guess that's
why all the mail we got is help I'm
trapped on a roof you know one of the
you're not hysterical in a way that the
lot of people on the right and the left
are about the tech giant's another place
where a lot of people are freaked out
again both on the right and the left are
about China and China as a rising
economic cultural national power
you're not and you have a section in the
book where you recount having gone to
China a couple years ago with some old
hands yes we've been working there for a
long time and you're generally very
optimistic about China what explains
that because you know this is certainly
one of Donald Trump's bete Noir
yeah well first place I like the Chinese
I'm it's a as foreign cultures go it is
one in which an American is more
comfortable than say for instance France
the Chinese a very similar sense of
humor to us some very hard working
people they like to have their fun and
it's kind of an easygoing place
obviously not about political dissent or
religious dissent we know that I'm
scared of the communist government of
China I do not think they wish the world
well and us specifically on the other
hand China has a successful military
history of none none whatsoever it may
have a large military that military has
no experience no practical experience in
the real world the last combat they were
involved in was some sort of border
conflict with Vietnam and I think they
got thrashed by the Vietnamese as did we
to be it music vaidamins knew how to
punch up their way let's give them
Kraden they did and they still do the
other thing about China that's that sort
of modifies one's opinion of the place
is to go even a few miles outside these
glittering coastal cities and glittering
capitals of the province where
everything seems super modern you're
going oh my gosh you know they're going
to overtake us in 15 minutes I mean
they've got 200 mile an hour trains you
know and Wi-Fi hotspots everywhere you
look go just 30 miles outside those
cities and you are back in another
millennia if it weren't for one skinny
electric wire running to these tiny
villages you really could be in the Tang
Dynasty it's an incredibly poor country
and I mean their gross domestic per
capita gross domestic product is like
way below places like Albania any place
in Europe so what I'm hearing is invest
in Albania that's what I yes now that
you're a certified financial yeah it is
yeah I would say that looks good to me
so China still has a I mean and you you
underscore China has grown massively
over the past you know Dec a few decades
but it's still it's barely the zero
baseline treto
any gross any growth looks absolutely
fabulous if you start out at zero which
is what they had was with Mao and the
Gang of Four no this is to take nothing
away from really impressive economic
growth but you know where was where is
that headed now it's interesting to me
that the current administration in China
seems to be reverting to its
totalitarian roots and and and that
indicates to me not so much something
terrifying it indicates to me that
they're terrified that in a in a country
that is on its way to becoming a
middle-class country with a lot of
stakeholders as we like to say with a
billion stakeholders that they're
worried that totalitarianism cannot
survive this kind of freedom this kind
of market freedom and this kind of
prosperity and I think they're right to
be worried now it's going to be
unpleasant while they try and reimpose
this totalitarianism and lots of people
are going to are being hurt and are
going to get hurt but in the end it's
not so guys well but when you talk about
Asia and rising both economic as well as
kind of cultural or demographic powers
you have more concerns about India and
Pakistan talk a little bit about that
well I really dislike two nuclear powers
who hate each other occupying the same
subcontinent that's not good
wait and now you're back to talking
about Trump and Hillary I suppose I am
except it's even worse than that
the yeah to have two very populous
countries armed to the teeth
with a demonstrated history demonstrates
Williams yes yes they they have gone at
it before to the great detriment of
their people their respected peoples and
and then plus you add elements of
religious fanaticism not just Muslim
religious fanaticism but Hindu religious
fanaticism too it's it's an ugly mix on
the other hand if I had to make a very
long-term bet talking a couple centuries
here on whether it's India or China and
will ultimately be the most powerful and
important country outside the United
States I would bet on India the mastery
of the English language is pervasive the
fundamental understandings of rule and
law of rule of law run deep
the innovative sensibility is very
strong and and it is a for whatever
flaws it as it is a democracy it is a
democracy which makes the likelihood
that will be a better democracy greater
in the future China has a lot of hurdles
to get over it it's done extremely well
economically but it has not dealt with
some of those structural fundamental
rule of law problems so let's let's keep
talking about the future in in this
sense you you extol capitalism and
individualism or a system of rights and
private property and ownership that
undergirded that precede it and yet at
one point you you coined a new term a
grumpy you you seem to have little but
contempt for many of the excrescences of
capitalists I'm 70 how does that yeah
but were you always like that no no I'm
I'm an old white man you know and of
course the the the cultural changes and
in many ways that sort of material
changes in the world since I was a mere
sprout of fifty do nothing but annoy me
one of the
towards the end of the book you you make
two statements that I found really
interesting and one is a callback to a
previous book Parliament of horrors yeah
where you say hey you know let's when
we're when we're talking about the
future of the country when we're talking
about the future of politics or
capitalism or society you say the [ __ ]
are us what do you mean by that of
beyond you know now that toys-r-us is
out of business I think this is a real
you know brand opportunity but what does
it mean to say I'm not talking about
Craigslist yeah or whatever the dating
app so maybe long past a dating stage no
the signal problem of democracy is and
always has been that that temptation to
vote ourselves rich try to vote
ourselves rich is that the single most
shaky foundation of democracy is when
everybody runs a government everybody
wants to benefit from that government
and it's what made many 18th century
philosophers feel that democracy could
never work and that democracy would
would go on the rocks of everybody
trying to vote themselves rich and even
in the European countries where that's
been more true than it has been in the
United States where they have much
larger benefit packages there has been
thank God there has been some measure of
restraint in the voters wanting the
government to give them everything but
it's a continual battle and and and it's
a battle that if we lose that battle we
ever lose that battle then democracy
will do your way do you worry about that
with I mean you are a quintessential I
mean you're you're I was gonna say a
definitional baby-boomer you're one of
the people who's defined what the
baby-boom means in its donors and you
wrote a fantastic book just a few years
ago about about the baby boomer
generation what is the role of people in
your kind of cohort to make sure because
it's it's Medicare and it's Social
Security and its expansion of Medicare
that is threatening to swallow the
entire federal budget what is the
responsibility of people in your
situation to say you
[ __ ] it were rich enough we're gonna
take care of ourselves and we're gonna
push the cash back down to younger
people that is our responsibility and we
have not taken hold of that
responsibility we are not living up to
that responsibility and we get if we get
enough rascal scooters through Medicare
will you lead a march down Washington
many men's electric chair a damp KITT
damping control yes exactly
know that the baby boom is just it's a
spoiled generation always has been a
spoiled generation and we are just
terrible about our insistence on all the
benefits that we think government should
give us I mean that Medicare isn't
means-tested is absolutely absolutely
ridiculous that the Social Security that
the age for retirement hasn't been
pushed ahead and and and you know I mean
I had to take and no choice but to take
Social Security when I turned 70 and a
half you know they basically make you do
it then I had no choice but to go on on
Medicare
there should be choices involved in this
and I would have gladly pushed my Social
Security all you have to do is crank up
the benefits a little bit for older
people and so if you don't take Social
Security till you're 80 you get a you
know you get a little extra bonus and
you take it early you get a little less
it's a fixable situation yeah but my
generation is not going to fix this
we're going to have to face the broke
the broke generation so the [ __ ] are
especially the baby so the other will
end on this you right towards the end of
the book something and I I have just
recently been reading all you know all
of the people are saying how we need
socialism now and socialism is the
answer you in three words sum up
something that I you know I think a lot
of us feel but don't know how to
articulate which is capitalism is fun
yeah explain that because that that's a
good note to go when is fun this is
basically why our kids want their
freedom from us they know that freedom
is fun sometimes it
proves to be a little too much fun and
what results is not fun at all but you
know capitalism or I like to say free
markets because as I pointed out
capitalism is everywhere you can't do
anything without capitalism but free
markets are freedom and freedom is more
fun than being enslaved than being
restricted and being institutionalized
than being in jail everybody knows that
in our heart that's why everybody in
their heart is a libertarian or I like
to think of it as 2/3 everybody's
two-thirds libertarian everybody
believes in individual liberty everybody
believes in individual dignity
individual responsibility so baby that's
what we need then the next tech giant
needs to create an app for individuals
have a responsibility app great idea
well we will leave it there
we've been talking with PJ O'Rourke his
latest book is none of my business
PJ explains money banking debt equity
assets liabilities and why he's not rich
and neither are you PJ O'Rourke thanks
so much for talking
[Music]